as thousands of students across the
valley continue school from home many of
you are wondering when they could
actually head back to class
that is what the school district's board
of trustees plan to discuss
in about an hour joe mohler is live with
what we might be able to expect to
happen tonight on this discussion
joe yeah well brian if your child
attends a ccsd
school computers like this have been
their classroom for the past seven
months or so now many children and
parents are wondering how much longer
exactly this will be going on now the
meeting this evening is set for five
o'clock and it will be virtual
board of trustees will discuss whether
or not they think schools should change
to a hybrid plan and that means
part in person and part remote trustees
will be going over
feedback from parents and others in the
community we won't hear a decision
tonight
it's all part of the first step in
possibly returning teachers and students
to the classroom
this is what one mother has to say about
having her child return
i do feel like if the cases do increase
they will shut down but should they
no because if you look in almost our
entire state there's open back up i mean
bars
hotels casinos whatever the case may be
so why can't our children go to school
and learn
information from the same districts over
and over again idea
also at the meeting leaders of the
mental the health district that is they
will provide trustees with the latest
cope and numbers now back out here live
we just want to clarify that this
meeting tonight is just starting this
discussion we don't expect to hear a
vote on this
until the 12th of next month reporting
live joe muller 8 news now